je me semble tellement bête je vois pas
se dire et j'ai pas la première à 18,6 à
leurs besoins avec des fougères si oui
ça oui quand je me suis sentie partir
j'ai rêvé que je faisais tout choc avec
le docteur steegmans pardon tu sais quoi
c'est comme si les gens possible ça mais
mon rêve tu sais les joueurs d'habitude
quoi les sessions partir et voir un
tunnel un tunnel et à la fin du tunnel
une lumière c'est ça les classiques et
toi tu fais quoi cacak avec tombe si oui
sur cette affaire a tendu
c'est bien elle méritait pas la tête
pourquoi tu décroches je ne lâche pas tu
deviennes l'érotique la mairie était
remis mais tu sais pas d'arrêter de
parler à partie et non mais ma chérie tu
sais que je respecte complètement
amnésique mais le problème c'est le
volume tu peux pas réputé avec un casque
ah non on n'est pas laide hastac max
cartier aussi les hormones à bord les ae
a pris max je pars ce soir et je
reviendrai pas c'est à dire passer à mon
cabinet dans une heure je serai dans une
heure chérif oui moi aussi j'y arrive on
arrive tout le monde arrive
moi ça va pas très fort en ce moment tu
sais ma chère ont pu le bridge c'est un
des derniers petits bonheurs pour déjà
ans angie comme un loft de plus de
plantes que pas la première à déposer
leur boulot hein avec des fougères si
c'est pour déjeuner non je te mets les
ensuite médical série docteur je vais
essayer de rencontrer quelqu'un au
coucher pourquoi ce traitement pour dire
tu peux crier sans problème et moi j'ai
l'habitude
puis c'est une bonne amie n'importe quoi
enchanter aussi
on a
ça me fait du bien de le voir en concert
à
je vais clôturer à quoi la photo de sa
carte vitale
vous voulez qu'on en parle un peu